[Music]
even during this age in which a great
new tv show seems to premiere every
couple of weeks there are a few clear
standouts
these all deserve to be included in the
best tv seasons of all time
breaking bad is one of those shows that
is about as perfect as television gets
that said the further along the show
progresses the more tense and
action-packed it becomes
choosing between seasons 4 and 5 is
tough but we have to give the nod to the
absolutely riveting final season of the
show
when season 5 starts walter white has
ascended to the top of the drug trade
he's eliminated his greatest rival and
seemingly nothing stands in his way
however such an astronomical high paves
the way for a devastating fall
the season pays off everything the story
has been setting up and throws in a few
killer twists along
the way including the moment walt's
brother-in-law hank
discovers walt is the mysterious meth
kingpin that he's been chasing for years
gotta say i don't like the way you're
looking at me right now
it all blows up in the final three
episodes one of which ozzy mandias is a
serious contender for the best episode
of television ever made
there are few tv series more divisive
than lost still despite the controversy
the show's first season is a genuinely
special piece of television
right from the pilot the season hooks
you in with stellar character work and
plenty of engaging mysteries
it builds its characters with stunning
efficiency and economy perfectly
balancing character histories with
exploration of the island's mysteries
later seasons would skew this balance
too far in either direction but the
show's debut season gives as much
attention to the mystery of the hatch
as it does the jack's relationship with
his departed father
from the perfect pilot to the riveting
finale season one of lost is just as
good today as it was when it first
aired i've looked into the eye of this
island
and what i saw was beautiful
parks and recreation really hit its
stride around its third season
but season four cemented the show as an
all-time great television comedy
even without the season-long through
line of leslie's city council campaign
season 4 provides several all-time great
episodes including ron and tammy's and
pawnee rangers
paul rudd's bobby newport absolutely
steals the entire season
as he wanders in and out of the season
with a guilelessness that few other
actors could pull off
we're not gonna quit the campaign
why would we do that because
i want it it's the most memorable most
quotable season of an already very
memorable and quotable comedy
you get fired i'll quit we'll leave
together i'm serious
move to a new city change our names burn
our fingertips off with acid
swap faces what we live in an era in
which superhero shows and movies are a
dime a dozen
the best way for one to stand out is to
center itself around unique themes
and jessica jones's first season does
this better than just about any entry in
the genre
the season serves as a 13 episode
meditation on trauma
abuse and recovering from toxic
relationships it never flinches from the
unpleasant trees of such subject matter
and handles it with the delicate touch
necessary
past that it's anchored by a very strong
hero and a very strong villain
kristen ritter shines as jessica while
david tennant turns out a uniquely
menacing performance as the villainous
kilgrave
shocking and emotionally resonant these
episodes will leave audiences reeling
for years
justified is anchored by the compelling
rivalry between timothy oliphant's u.s
marshal raylan gibbons
and the magnetic criminal boyd crowder
played by walton goggins
what are you packing you'll pay to find
that out
oh you got ice cold water running
through your veins
however as stellar is the interplay
between these two is it's not the focus
of the series best season
that honor goes to the second season
story revolving around the bennett
family the bennetts run a crime
enterprise
dealing in everything from moonshine to
marijuana raelyn is charged with
bringing them down and as you might
expect things don't go according to plan
the way this season establishes the
series setting of parliament kentucky as
the kind of hometown you can never fully
escape
makes for a pitch perfect story and a
great piece of development for raylen
himself
a particular note is margot martindale
doing what is easily the best work of
her career as mags
a terrifying rattlesnake of a crime boss
cougar i know you're sorry
that's why it's gonna hurt so much you
have to do this
bloodline revolves around the ray burns
a large family residing in the florida
keys
when their oldest son danny returns from
an extended disappearance
events are set in motion that lead to
danny's death at the hand of his brother
john
the show chronicles the march to dany's
murder non-linearly
rather than obsessing about the plot
most a bloodline is carried through
conversations
micro-regressions and slowly simmering
feuds bloodline's first season
is an active compelling family drama
that will leave you screaming at your tv
by the finale's closing moments
season 4 of new girl sees the show
regain its footing after an uneven third
season and truly become the best
possible version of itself
more than any season of new girl these
episodes delve into hilariously
exploring modern dating
like when jess downloads a pseudo tinder
app for the first time
that said the easy standout is
background check which ranks among the
greatest tv episodes of all time
the story sees the gang subject to an
in-home background check as part of
winston's application to become a police
officer
over the course of the examination the
crew spirals into insanity
i just need you to pretend like uh
you're in a relationship with this grown
man that i know
ah i did not think this through did i
think it's true easily one of the other
sitcoms in recent memory new girl was
never more irreverent or wonderful than
it was during its fourth season
by the time the sixth season of game of
thrones comes around the story has
progressed past the territory covered by
the book series it's drawn from
this left the show runners free to run
wild with the story and take it in new
surprising directions that can't be
spoiled by the books
they build a number of conflicts to a
head like the war between the starks and
the boltons for control of the north
and pepper in a hefty number of game
changing revelations
[Music]
from daenerys finally making her way to
westeros to the battle of the bastards
game of thrones sixth season is riveting
genre television
in just eight episodes true detective's
first season accomplished more in terms
of creativity and critical acclaim than
some shows do in 10 season runs
the mini-series stars woody harrelson
and matthew mcconaughey as surly
detectives attempted to solve a series
of murders
the story is told non-linearly and
features some seriously dark
philosophical tangents
which creates even more mysteries for
the viewer to solve
you get any sleep last night i don't
sleep
i just dream
true detective wears its influences on
its sleeve from the start
it's packed with lovecraftian themes and
structure making a story about two men
hunting a killer feel otherworldly
it borrows from plenty of well-loved
literature but the show doesn't simply
rip off these stories
instead it uses them to create a depth
of influence to give viewers more to
dissect
i contemplate the moment in the garden
the idea of allowing your own
crucifixion
when this is combined with the dense
themes fully formed characters and
complex plot
the result is a show you can analyze and
break down a million different ways
it's massively compelling television the
likes of which we haven't seen since
much of the first season of ai sci-fi
drama westworld centers on the idea of a
maze
the show's characters both human and
robot find themselves drawn into a
conspiracy involving a maze symbol left
by one of westworld's original founders
while it's easy to get distracted by the
stellar performances and special effects
the mystery is what makes the show so
memorable and addictive
i think there's deeper meaning hiding
under all that
something the person who created it
wanted to express
modern tv shows love mysteries but few
shows manage to pay them off in ways
that don't cheat the viewer in some way
westworld is the rare mystery that never
makes this mistake
its plot is structured like the maze it
revolves around by the time we reach the
center of the maze it's just as shocking
to us as it is to them
it's an amazing start to an amazing
series
few shows have changed the game like the
sopranos the modern concept of prestige
television can be traced back to the
runaway success of hbo's mob drama
the whole run is excellent right up to
the finale and the acclaimed awards
speak for themselves
look no further than the show's
immaculate second season as evidence as
to why it still holds the reputation it
enjoys today
it used to be far more outside the norm
for shows to kill major characters with
little to no
warning the sopranos made its bones in
this trade and focuses its sophomore
season on tony soprano's best friend
becoming an fbi informant
the show spirals to an inevitable
confrontation between the two that plays
out just as shockingly today as it did
when it first aired
even with all the stellar prestige tv
shows on the air today
we can't forget the original there's
very little to say about the wire that
hasn't already been said
it's perhaps the single most acclaimed
television show of all time
the wires tale of the complex lives of
baltimore cops and criminals
form a tremendously powerful narrative
about life death
poverty corruption and finding the light
amidst it all
while every batch of episodes has its
strengths season 4 of the wire is easily
the best the show has to offer
and when you're talking about the best
season of possibly the best show of all
time
you know it's something special the
show's fourth season sees the narrative
weave a story about the baltimore school
system
and follows the lives of four young boys
who have grown up in the area
while there are other stories going on
throughout the season the four boys
become the season's linchpin
season four is where the show stops
asking questions and starts giving
answers
boldly claiming that in a world ravaged
by systematic poverty
there is no level playing field for
those who grow up in it their fate is
predetermined and impossible to escape
as street dealer bodhi tells hard-nosed
cop mcnulty
this game is rigged man
you like the little [ __ ] on the
chessboard pawns